as a number of coronavirus cases surges
we are looking at how the virus affects
men and women differently well they get
infected at similar rates research shows
that men are more likely to suffer worse
outcomes they are as much as 2.4 times
more likely to die for example senior
medical correspondent dr. turn the ruler
reports that doctors are now seeing if
giving men so-called female hormones can
help when kovat 19 hit the pegaso family
in april
Leo big as au was more worried about his
wife Karolina who had a history of
pneumonia and asthma copd rotation on
high cholesterol nothing faster and
easier and it was all the way while
Karolina got stronger at South Bay
Hospital near Tampa Florida two doors
down Leo was intubated doctors gave him
only a 40% chance of survival one month
after his triumphant homecoming Leo was
still weak and needed supplemental
oxygen why a healthy man like Leo got so
much sicker than a woman with underlying
conditions is likely due to a
combination of behavior genetics and
hormones one of the biggest questions
that I have is the extent to which these
differences between men and women are
being mediated by our hormones versus
our genes
Sabra Cline studies gender differences
in immune response to viruses and
vaccinations at the Johns Hopkins
Bloomberg School of Public Health when
something like a virus like the SARS
Coby - virus enters our body's immune
system of women tend to respond more
rapidly and more robustly with other
viruses such as the flu and hepatitis
women tend to clear the infection faster
than men and women generally mount
stronger immune responses from vaccines
the advantage may lie in the X
chromosome which carries genes linked to
immune system function while women have
a pair of X chromosomes men have only
one I think if there's more than one
reason or one one thing that's
potentially contributing to women
faring better in this in this disease
dr. Sarah ghandahar II is studying
whether the Cova 19 gender gap could be
linked to the hormones that make men and
women different estrogen testosterone
and progesterone which supports
pregnancy the hope is that progesterone
will get will get to the disease when
it's at a level that there's not an
overwhelming amount of inflammation 40
men with kovat 19 and dr. ghandahar ii
study will receive a five-day course of
progesterone to see if it raises their
odds of surviving on par with women i
really my dad get as bad as he was i
really expected kind of roles to be
swapped
when briana Lawtons family got infected
with the corona virus the florida nurse
thought her mother Cecilia was most at
risk because of her history of high
blood pressure diabetes and respiratory
illness but while Cecilia recovered at
home it just happened so fast
her husband Marvin lost his battle with
the corona virus and died in the
hospital he was only 60 years old we got
that call to me it just seemed like you
know this has to be somebody else it
couldn't be us
my daughter struggles with the guilt
that she couldn't save her dad and dr.
Terra Narula joins us now doctor we
mentioned genetics we mentioned hormones
as possible contributors to this gap
could it also be the way that men behave
the things they do to their bodies to
begin with
absolutely Tony it really is this
complex interplay between genes hormones
and behavior we talked about the X
chromosome genes in the piece but even
the same genes that we share some in men
can be turned on differently than the
ones in women when you look at hormones
all of our immune cells almost all of
them have receptors for estrogen
progesterone in testosterone but you
can't discount the behavior we know that
men tend to smoke or drink more than
women they may seek care less often or
seek care less quickly if they have
symptoms
women there may be different
occupational exposures and even studies
have shown that men tend to wash their
hands less often so all of those are
important to factor in alright dr. taryn
the rule important reminders there about
how men can intervene on their own
behalf if they choose to thank you very
much